اخر ما حرر بخصوص الخلافات وهذه الاشتباك
اللفظي داخل الطاقم الوزاري الامني الذي
سجل ذروه في الحمله التي يقودها نتنياهو
ورهطه ضد القيادتين السياسيه العسكريه
والامنيه الاسرائيليه هو ما نقلته القناه
الثانيه عش تحديدا صباح هذا اليوم والليله
من عن مسؤولين عسكريين كبار كما قالت
والذين قالوا انهم وفي الوقت الذي يحاربون
فيه في قطاع ز وفي الضفه الغربيه وفي
لبنان فان الطاقم الوزاري الامني المصغر
المعروف بالكابينه يقوم بمحاربتهم وهذا
مؤشر على عمق عمل فقدان الثقه القائم سواء
بين القيادتين العسكريه او السياسيه او
فقدان الثقه لدى الشارع الاسرائيلي
بقيادته بقيادته السياسيه التي يقودها
نتنياهو التصريحات التي وردت وردات الفعل
على لسان مسؤولين كثر من بينهم بطبيعه
الحال كما تم بثه قبل قليل للوزير في مجلس
الحرب بيني جانس وزعيم المعارضه يعير لبيد
هناك تصريح ايضا قوي وتغريده كانت لوزير
لرئيس الحكومه وزير الدفاع الاسبق ايهود
براك والذي شن هجوما على نتنياهو وطالب
بتنحيته وتنحيه حكومته وحذرهم من مواصله
حملاتهم ضد الجيش كذلك الاصوات الصادره في
الشارع الاسرائيلي التي ترى و بان هذه
الحمله انما تتم بايعاز من نتنياهو شخصيا
الذي يسعى لدحر المسؤوليه عن الفشل الذريع
الامني الاستخباراتي والعسكري في السابع
من اكتوبر وعدم تحقيق انجازات حتى الان
على القياده العسكريه ممثله برئيس هيئه
الاركان ولذلك جاء استغلال قرار هيئه
الاركان ورئيسه هيرتس هاليفي بتشكيل طاقم
تحقيق داخلي من عسكريين سابقين بقياده
شاؤول مفاز وزير الدفاع ورئيس هيئه
الاركان الاسبق الذي في عهده تم تنفيذ
عمليه الانفصال عن قطاع غزه جاء استغلال
ذلك من قبل نتنياهو
ومؤيديه في محاوله لمواصله الحمله ضده ما
جرى خلال جلسه مجلس الوزراء التي كانت من
المفترض المصغر بطبيعه الحال التي كان من
المفترض ان تكون مخصصه من اجل بحث الرؤيه
الاسرائيليه لليوم التالي للحرب اننا
نتنياهو اولا يريد التهرب من بحث هذه
القضيه وان كان الامريكيون والقياده
العسكريه الاسرائيليه الامنيه تطالبه
بضروره
تحديد محتوى سياسي لهذه الحرب في حال وضعت
اوزارها لكنه يتهرب منذ فتره وفي كل
الاجتماعات يؤجل هذا الامر ويبدو ان تحريك
ادواته الوزاريه ممثله بالوزير ام سالم
ورجب من الليكود ووزراء راي الصهيونيه
الدينيه وعظمه يهوديه بنفير وسموت ضد رئيس
الاركان خلال الجلسه الليله قبل الماضيه
التي استمرت ثلاثه ساعات ونصف الساعه من
الصراخ وايضا تعالي الاصوات هذه كان هدفها
ايضا التهرب مجددا من بحث هذا الموضوع
بالاضافه بطبيعه الحال الى توجيه سهامه
نحو رئيس هيئه الاركان والقياديه الامنيه
والعسكريه لتحمي لما المسؤوليه عن هذا
الفشل وواضح بان نتنياهو مخاوفه كبيره جدا
بانه عندما تضع الحرب اوزارها فان لجنه
تحقيق الرسميه ستقوم في اسرائيل لجنه
التحقيق او طاقم التحقيق الذي اقامه رئيس
هيئه الاركان ووفق المصادر الاسرائيليه
العليم هو من صلاحيات رئيس الاركان لانه
شان داخلي للجيش ولا علاقه له بلجنه
التحقيق التي ستقام بعد انتهاء هذه الحرب
لكن في اسرائيل يرى كثيرون بان ما جرى في
جلسه الطاقم الوزاري الامني المصغر
الكابينت الليله قبل الماضيه كان بمثابه
بروفا او نموذج لما سيكون عليه الحال
عندما تنتهي الحرب وتبدا لجنه التحقيق
اعمالها وكثيرون تذكروا هنا الحمله التي
كانت ضد رئيس هيئه الاركان دادو بن ددو
العزر بعد حرب عام ثلاثه 7 اكتوبر حيث
اضطر الى الانتحار في نهايتها بعد ان
دحرجت القياده السياسيه ايضا المسؤوليه
عليه ويبدو ان نتنياهو يكرر هذا المشهد
حاليا وفق بعض المصادر الاسرائيليه العلي
والتي ترى بان استمرار هذه الحمله من قبل
نتنياهو وجماعته في لخدمه مصالح داخليه
خاصه وحزب سياسيه من شانها ان تضعف الجبهه
الداخليه وتضعف الجيش هذا الجيش ووفق ما
نقلته صحيفه ه ارس بقلم احد اكبر محرريها
يوس فيرتر وصلت بعض مصادره لقناعه انها
بعد ثلاثه اشهر من الحرب لم فعلا لم تحقق
اهداف او انجازات استراتيجيه وفق الاهداف
التي حققتها حددتها الحكومه في بدايه
الحرب حماس لازالت قوه عسكريه ولا زالت
قوه سلطويه في قطاع غزه لم يتم اعاده
المحتجزين الاسرى في قطاع غزه كما انها لم
تحقق بعد الامن الكامل لسكان اغلاف غزه
الذين نزحوا كي يعودوا الى هناك وما زالت
صافرات الانذار تدوي بين الحين والاخر كما
جرى في ال 24 ساعه الماضيه حيث دوت مرتين
في عزقلان وفي غلاف غزه كما ان المعارك ما
تسال الضاريه تحديدا في منطقه خانيونس وان
كان الجيش قد تحدث مرارا عن انه يحقق
تقدما ويقاتل فوق الارض وتحت الارض
بالمناسبه القوات الاسرائيليه التي تقوم
بهذه الحرب هي من قوات نخبه النخبه في
الجيش الاسرائيلي مثل شلدا التابع الوحده
الخاصه التابعه لسلاح الجو وا شيته 13 وهي
الوحده النخبه التابعه لسلاح البحريه
وسياره متكال دوريه هيئه رئاسه الاركان
وهي
اعلى النخب في الجيش الاسرائيلي هذه القوى
الثلاثه هي التي تقوم مزوده بادوات
تكنولوجيه واسلحه حديثه للغايه لكن رغم
ذلك كله التقديرات في اسرائيل انها لم
تحقق تقدما بطيئا لكنها لا تحقق ذاك
التقدم الذي من شانه ان يقضي على اربعه
كتائب لكتا كتائب القسام من النخبه ايضا
تخوض المعركه ضدها تحت الارض وفوق الارض
بهذا التوقيت بالذات نحن في نهايه الاسبوع
الاول من الشهر الاول من هذا العام وهو
الموعد الذي كان قد حدده الامريكيون للجيش
الاسرائيلي لبدء المرحله الثالثه من هذه
الحرب وقد بدا اعاده الانتشار منذ يومين
في مناطق شمالي قطاع غزه لكن في منطقه
خانيونس حتى الان المعارك ووسط قطاع غزه
ما تزال قواته تتواجد داخل هذه المناطق
نسف العديد من الانفاق حسب تعبيره وتمكن
من قتل العديد من كوادر ومقاتلي القسام
لكنه ووفق تقديراته لم يحقق ذاك التقدم
هذا الوضع ونحن في اليوم ال2 للحرب دون
تحقيق انجازات استراتيجيه تقرب الاهداف هو
من اسباب ايضا تصاعد الخلافات وتلك ال
الاشتباك اللفظي عالي الصوت الذي جرى في
الطاقم الوزاري الامني المصغر الليله قبل
الماضيه وهو ما يؤكد وفق مقولات الجميع
بان الفشل يتيم لذلك يدحرج جونه من من
ناحيه الى اخرى وان لا انجاز واذا تحقق
الانجاز سيكون له اباء كثر في اسرائيل لكن
حتى الان هذا لم يتحقق اسرائيل الان تنتظر
ايضا وصول وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه هذا
الاسبوع في زياره خامسه وهو ياتي في ملفات
كثيره من بينها الرؤيه الاسرائيليه
للمرحله ما بعد الحرب ايضا حاوله اجبار
اسرائيل على دفع الاموال التي اقتنصت من
عائدات الضرائب للسلطه
الفلسطينيه زياده ما يوصف بالمساعدات
الانسانيه وادخالها لقطاع غزه وتجنيب
المدنيين ويلات الحرب بالاضافه بطبيعه
الحال الى محاوله الحقول ومنع انفجار حرب
على الحدود مع لبنان وهو ما يعمل عليه
ايضا عامس هوشن المبعوث الرئاسي الامريكي
الذي جاء الى تل ابيب وتوجه الى بيروت على
امل ان يتمكن من ايجاد تسويه في 13 نقطه
حدوديه خلافيه بريه بين لبنان واسرائيل
على امل ان يشكل ذلك مدخلا لنزع فتيل حرب
ممكنه او محتمله على طول الحدود مع لبنان
وهو ما كان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي خلال
تفقده قواته هناك امس قد اشار الى ان
اسرائيل تفضل التوصل بادوات دبلوماسيه
وسياسيه الى تسويه تضمن ابعاد حزب الله عن
الحدود وعوده الاسرائيليين الى بلداتهم 21
التين نزحوا عنها المتا قمل الحدود لكن
اذا لم يتحقق ذلك فانها ا ستستخدم الادوات
العسكريه او الخيار العسكري وان الوقت
ينفذ على حد تعبيره لكن من الواضح بانه
وسط هذا التوتر المشدود حتى اخره واضح ان
الامور سواء مع لبنان او في قطاع غزه وفي
الضفه الغربيه تتواصل في تصعيد من جانب
قوات الاحتلال الضفه الغربيه كانت عرضه
لسلسله من الاقتحامات هذه الليله كما هي
منذ بدايه الحرب واعداد المعتقلين تتزايد
بشكل كبير كل ليله وفجر كل يوم شكرا لك
وليد عمري مدير مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا من
رام الله